hello everyone my name is Christina
Mosely and I'm going to associate
professor of medicine and epidemiology
in the division of infectious diseases
at the University of Alabama at
Birmingham welcome to this talk
sponsored by lab routes and the
infectious diseases virtual event my
topic today is is bacterial vaginosis a
sexually transmitted infection and this
is actually a very controversial part of
our field right now and so today I will
be talking about some of the evidence
for and against whether or not B B is a
sexually transmitted infection I have
several disclosures for this
presentation listed a slide one other
thing I want to mention before I get
into the presentation is that I will be
accepting questions on this presentation
via email so if you have any questions
or need any clarifications please send a
message and I will respond back to your
soon as I can
the outline for this talk today I will
do a brief review of the US and global
prevalence of bacterial vaginosis its
diagnosis and current treatment then I
will spend more time reviewing the
epidemiology of bacterial vaginosis
particularly as it relates to sexual
transmission and during my talk about
that I'm going to discuss a few current
hypotheses that we have regarding the
etiology of BV presuming that it is an
STI and these hypotheses really deal
about whether or not BV is caused by a
single pathogen or a poly microbial
consortium of pathogens that lead to B B
you
bacterial vaginosis is the most common
cause of vaginal discharge the u.s.
prevalence per the last in Haynes data
was about 30 percent so one in every
three women approximately BV is
associated with multiple adverse
gynecologic and reproductive health
outcomes including preterm birth low
birth weight
post-operative gynecological infections
and increased risk for acquisition and
transmission of HIV and sexually
transmitted infections we do know that
BV is characterized by depletion of
vaginal lactobacilli and increases in
facultative and strict anaerobic
bacteria I have several of these listed
on this slide as they are very pertinent
to this presentation today so
gardnerella vaginalis is a facultative
anaerobic bacteria involved in BB and
several key strict anaerobic bacteria
our private television at a podium
vagine' a BB a be one through three mega
sphere species and some media species
slide comes from a paper that was just
published about three months ago in the
sexually transmitted diseases Journal
showing the current global burden of
bacterial vaginosis around the world I
had mentioned it's about 30% prevalence
in the United States and similar
prevalences in other countries around
the world between 24 23 percent up to 29
percent also in the figure to the right
you can see the prevalence of BV
stratified by race and also non pregnant
women versus pregnant women and as you
can see here African American women that
are pregnant actually have the highest
prevalence of BV worldwide according to
this recent publication there are two
ways that we currently diagnose BV the
first is as I'm sure you're all well
aware of the am so criteria which is
what we use in clinical practice and you
have to have three out of four of these
criteria needed for a BV diagnosis these
include a homogeneous vaginal discharge
a vaginal pH that's elevated greater
than four point five a positive whisked
test and greater than 20% of Clue cells
per high-power field on a wet mount of
vaginal secretions
the second way we currently diagnose BV
is more done in research settings which
is by the Nugent score this is performed
on a vaginal Gram stain which is looked
at under the microscope and I have three
pictures on this slide to the right
showing three different categories of
the Nugent score a Nugent score of zero
to three is a lactobacillus predominant
vaginal flora where you see a lot of
these gram positive rods that are
vaginal lactobacilli and you can see the
squamous epithelial cells at the top are
very clean looking and you can see the
nucleus very well anujan score four to
six is consistent with intermediate
vaginal flora with the emergence of that
facultative anaerobe I had mentioned
gardnerella vaginalis here you start to
see some of the stippling of the vaginal
epithelial cell and it's not as clean
with all the lactobacilli that you see
on the slide above and finally a nujin
score of seven to ten which is the
bottom picture on the right is
consistent with bv and this is pretty
much the complete disappearance of
healthy vaginal lactobacilli with
numerous gardnerella vaginalis and
mobile Uncas other strict anaerobes and
as you can see here this vaginal
epithelial so in the picture on the
right bottom right is completely covered
with all of these bacteria and you
cannot clearly see the nucleus of the
cell also the borders of the cell are
obscured so this is a classic clue cell
that you may also see on a wet mount of
vaginal fluid
our treatment recommendations for BV in
this country are based on the 2015 CDC
STD treatment guidelines I do want to
call your attention that new guidelines
are currently being worked on and they
are planned to come out in 2020 next
year by the CDC so be sure to check that
out to see if any of these current
recommendations are updated or changed
when that becomes available but
currently right now the recommended
regimens are 500 milligrams twice a day
of metronidazole orally or metronidazole
gel daily for five days or clindamycin
cream intravaginally at bedtime for
seven days there are several alternative
medications including tinidazole
two different doses and two different
durations of therapy oral clindamycin
and then clindamycin ovules which are
all listed on this slide
it's important to recognize that despite
these treatment options that we
currently have available BV recurrence
is very common and this is shown very
well in a prior study by Jacky Sobel and
colleagues of time to be be recurrent in
a group of women that they followed for
28 weeks they had actually randomized
these women to either placebo or a
suppressive metronidazole therapy and by
28 weeks 75% of the women that were on
the placebo arm of this study had a BV
recurrence compared to 51% of women who
had a B the recurrence that were taking
suppresses metronidazole therapy in this
study the BV recurrence was extremely
common really in both arms of this study
however more so in the placebo arm of
women that weren't taking any type of
therapy
we think that currently one of the major
reasons that recurrence is so common
among women with BV despite treatment is
that BV is a biofilm community and
really the biofilm portrays what you're
seeing on these clue cells it's
currently believed that the Clouseau is
actually a BV it's covered by all of
these strict and facultative anaerobic
bacteria which comprise a biofilm
community and that is what is occurring
on these vaginal epithelial cells
causing the stippling of the cells that
we saw in the pictures on the previous
slides one of the Sentinel studies to
identify that BB is a biofilm community
was published in 2005 by Alexander
Osinski and he found in that study that
the biofilm is mainly composed of
gardnerella vaginalis which composed 16
and 90% of the biofilm mass at a podium
vagine' 8 comprised a smaller proportion
of the biofilm and then lactobacillus
species comprise a very small proportion
of the biofilm it's important to note in
this Sentinel study that he only had
probes for these bacteria and so there
may likely be other BBS sa bacteria that
are also part of the biofilm however we
currently don't know exactly what those
are and is an area of active research in
this field so I kind of want to get into
the epidemiology of BV with regards to
sexual transmission there is a large
body of data if you review the
literature which supports the sexual
transmission of B be associated bacteria
however there is a big controversy in
the field as I previously mentioned
about what causes B B we currently don't
know if it's one pathogen that causes B
B or a group of pathogens that causes B
B that could both potentially be
sexually transmitted
however some of the epidemiological data
that we have available has shown that
bebe is associated with inconsistent
condom use and increased numbers of
recent and lifetime sexual partners
women with bebe have an earlier median
age of sexual debut than women without
the most significant risk factor for
incident BV or a new case of BV is a new
sexual partner while that for recurrent
BV is a regular sexual partner there's
also been found a high level of
concordance of having BV or not having
BB by Nugent score that has been found
in women who have sex with women and
their female sexual partners so a lot of
these data are summarized in the papers
listed below that I have on this slide
and correspond with a large body of
epidemiological data that supports that
BB may be sexually transmitted
as I have alluded to earlier in this
presentation there are likely some key
BV associated bacteria that have been
discussed and highly looked at in the
literature and I have them listed here
on this slide gardnerella vaginalis is
definitely one of them at a podium prep
atella lepto trachea mega sparrow type
one the need the SBC's and the cluster
idiot light bacteria BVA be one two and
three all of these bacteria have high
specificity for bebe and particularly
with regards to gardnerella vaginalis it
has been found to be present in 95 to
100 percent of bebe cases gardnerella
vaginalis is also the BB associate
bacteria that has had the most research
done on it to date over the past 50 to
60 years
these key B be associated bacteria on
the slide are all more common and easy
compared to normal flora
however only gardnerella vaginalis at a
podium vagine' a mega sparrow type 1 and
b be abie to have been found to be
independently associated with BB
in addition gardnerella mega sfera type
1 b ba b to b be a b3 sunitha and lepto
trachea are also rare or absent and
sexually unexposed women
in the literature gardnerella vaginalis
as I have mentioned has been studied the
most with regards to the pathogenesis of
BV it's been found to be more virulent
than other B be associated bacteria this
was shown very nicely in several of the
studies I have listed on this slide
which are in vitro studies of virulence
factors of gardnerella at a podium
prevotella and mobile ancas only
gardnerella vaginalis demonstrated all
three variants factors in this study
which included adherence to host
receptor sites on vaginal epithelial
cells cytotoxicity specific for host
receptor cells which includes the
vaginal lisen which is produced by
gardnerella vaginalis and is a pore
forming toxin that lysis cells
gardnerella also has been found to be
able to start BB biofilm formation which
is extremely important as I mentioned
that the biofilm is a big part of BV the
authors of these studies suggested that
other organisms or other BB Associated
bacteria besides gardnerella vaginalis
may be relatively a variant opportunists
that colonize the BV biofilm after
initiation of infection by gardnerella
it's also important to note that
gardnerella produces a solid ace and
parola days which degra gate mucin and
IgA in the vaginal tract other studies
have also shown in vitro that
gardnerella is more virulent than other
BB Associated bacteria it's been shown
that gardnerella has the greatest
capacity to adhere to vaginal epithelial
cells in the presence of lactobacillus
course potus which is thought to be one
of the predominant healthy vaginal flora
this is compared to a de Peau B improve
at Ella mobile Uncas and feasel
bacterium
in addition the effect of gardnerella
vaginalis biofilms on the adherence and
growth of other BB associate bacteria
has been quantified by quantitative PCR
interestingly gardnerella vaginalis
derived a growth benefit from the
addition of a second BB Associated
bacterial species regardless of the
species
conversely gardnerella vaginalis
biofilms enhance the growth of private
Ella into a minor extent future
bacterium in this study so this leads me
to one of the hypotheses in the field
about the pathogenesis of bee bee and
this is actually a paper that our group
at UAB published five years ago now for
our hypothetical model for the
pathogenesis of
incident BV and we base this model on an
extensive review of the literature at
that time and you can see the citation
for this paper if you're interested in
reading it in more depth but basically
we hypothesize that BV is a sexually
transmitted infection and that
gardnerella vaginalis is the primary
pathogen that if sexually transmitted
will cause BB in the exposed partner
basically in this model we suggested
that a virulent strain of gardnerella
vaginalis would be sexually transmitted
come in adhere to the vaginal epithelial
cells and compete with the lactobacilli
to the point where gardnerella overtakes
them and allows its growth to expand
then once gardnerella vaginalis comes in
as a facultative anaerobe into this
environment starts multiplying and
expanding the lactose are going down we
hypothesized that other BV associated
bacteria would start over growing since
gardnerella vaginalis had changed the
vaginal environment to make it more
suitable for anaerobic growth we thought
that several of these other BV
Associated bacteria would be present in
very low numbers and women normally and
acquired during birth from their mother
and once gardnerella starts this process
of making an anaerobic environment and
growing these other BB Associated
bacteria may over grow with that the BV
biofilm would be formed and causing some
of the symptoms that you see with BB
so this was our hypothesis back in 2014
however there are some proponents to
this hypothesis there are some in the
field that state that how can
gardnerella vaginalis be the primary
pathogen in bacterial vaginosis
if it's been found in virgins if it's an
STD and it's causing BV how can this be
happening in women who are not having
sex and so one of the early studies on
this topic that's controversial was
published by bumps in the obstetrics and
gynaecology Journal in 1988 and in this
study they had 52 postman archaeal
virginal women there were ages 14 to 17
years old and 12% of these women had BV
by am so criteria and 17% of the women
had gardnerella vaginalis by vaginal
culture in contrast rates of other STD
such as gonorrhea chlamydia and
trichomonas were very low in this group
of women which you can see all this
depicted in this table that I have on
the slide and so you know the
investigators in this study says how can
gardnerella vaginalis be a BV STD
pathogen is it seen in virginal women
the interesting thing about these
virginal women is who they were in this
study so the women that participated in
this study were actually the the
daughters of several of the people
involved in conducting the study and
their friends and so it's a little
suspect if they were actually being
truthful about their sexual history at
that time although of course we can't
prove that now twenty twenty-five years
later in addition the authors of the
study only asked about penile vaginal
sex to these women and not other forms
of sex which could potentially transmit
a bacterial pathogen so there is a
little controversy about this study
in addition Shafer published another
study of virginal women that found a
small proportion of gardnerella
vaginalis in the Journal of pediatrics
there were 19 non sexually active women
in this study compared to 152 sexually
active women and they found gardnerella
vaginalis in about 30% of the women of
these 19 women that did not report any
sexual activity
proponents of the gardnerella vaginalis
hypothesis also state that it has not
fulfilled Koch's postulates by itself
for disease causation which this can get
kind of complicated and I have it
summarized here on the slide and if
anyone has a question about this feel
free to email me later on after you've
heard this presentation I'm happy to
discuss but there's four postulates for
Koch's postulates first the
microorganism must be found in abundance
and all organisms suffering from the
disease but should not be fun and
healthy organisms
so gardnerella vaginalis has been found
in 92 percent of women with bv by
culture this is all in the sentinel
studies done about bv in the 1950s by
gardner and dukes however some say that
gardnerella does not fulfill this first
postulate because it has since been
found in normal healthy women and
virginal women second the microorganism
must be isolated from a disease organism
and grown in pure culture this has been
done with gardnerella vaginalis and 141
women with BB so this one is not
controversial the third postulate is
that the cultured microorganism should
cause disease when introduced into a
healthy organism in original studies of
gardnerella vaginalis only one of 13
women inoculated with it developed the
clinical symptoms of BV it's interesting
to note however that in this study this
original study that the type of
gardnerella vaginalis that was
inoculated into healthy women was not in
the exponential phase of growth it was
in the lag phase of growth so they
actually reproduced this experiment
several years later where they
inoculated women with gardnerella
vaginalis isolates in the exponential
phase of growth and and more of the
women developed BV than previously
of course these experiments were done in
the 1950s in the 1960s before the IRB
was standardized in this country and
unfortunately for good reasons these
types of experiments experiments cannot
be reproduced today because of the major
ethics associated with them finally the
fourth postulate is that the
microorganism must be reais elated from
an inoculated disease experimental host
and identified as being identical to the
original specific causative agent
so pure cultures of gardnerella
vaginalis have been obtained from one
patient inoculated with this organism
who developed B B so this postulate has
been fulfilled
so really postulates 1 and 3 are the
ones that are still controversial to
this day
additional proponents of this hypothesis
state that the microbiology of BB is
heterogeneous you would think that if
gardnerella was the pathogen all the
women would just have gardnerella
however when they've looked at the
constitution of the vaginal microbiome
in vaginal microbiome studies they have
found that BB is a syndrome and not a
pathogen and one woman's BV may not be
the same as another woman's BB so you
have subject a and subject B on this
slide of which different proportions of
certain B be associated bacteria have
been found and they're not exactly the
same as you can clearly tell by looking
at these two pie charts so that's a
little bit of controversial as well in
the field
and finally proponents of the
gardnerella vaginalis hypothesis state
or a b b being an STD state that if that
is actually true if we treat a woman
that has B B we should also treat her
male sexual partner just like we do for
all the other STDs and that should
reduce recurrent rate recurrence rates
in that female woman however there have
been six male partner treatment trials
of women with recurrent BV who
randomized the men their male partners
to either certain doses of metronidazole
or placebo and interestingly five out of
these six trials did not show a
significant benefit and so currently
partner treatment for women with BB is
not recommended by the CDC based on
these older trials I do want to note
here on this chart we have summarized
these trials in a recent publication
that our group did you can see that
these trials were conducted in the early
or to mid 1985 all the way up until 1997
so these are definitely older trials and
I will mention that some colleagues here
in this country Jackie Sobel again and
James Webb key here at UAB are actually
conducting a current male partner
treatment trial of women with recurrent
BV in the current error to see if it
shows a significant effect so be on the
lookout for that data coming out in the
next one to two years because that trial
is currently wrapping up enrollment I
have a slide here talking about the one
trial that reported that male partner
treatment had an effect on BV and the
female partners and this was published
in the Journal of Family Practice in
1989 by mingle at all and you can read
this study to see what they found but at
two weeks there was no clear difference
in clinical cure rate by B weeks by art
by either arm of the study however at
two and five weeks women whose partners
were treated had less BB by vaginal Gram
stain in a
at eight weeks women whose partners were
treated were more likely to report
resolution of their symptoms however the
study did have multiple methodological
issues their results were presented
graphically and their aspect sizes were
not stated in this study
so dr. Maeda actually wrote a very good
article on the limitations of these
prior male partner treatment studies and
providing rationale that new treatment
trials and the current error should be
conducted so I put on a slide all of the
limitations she had discussed about
these prior male partner treatment
trials because this is also
controversial whether or not these
trials are truly rigorous enough to tell
us that we should definitely not be
treating male partners a women with BV
in all six of those trials the study
drug was delivered to the male by the
female and no measures of compliance
were noted which could have affected
outcomes in addition these trials had
insufficient power to detect reasonable
effect sizes randomization methods were
deficient or insufficient Lee reported
adherence to therapy and the men was
infrequently reported and many of the
treatment regimens and used in these
trials including a single to gram dose
of metronidazole is now not considered
effective therapy for BV clearly as I
mentioned one of the recommended
therapies currently in the 2015 CDC STD
treatment guidelines is a seven-day dose
of 500 milligrams twice a day of
metronidazole
so this sort of led me to a study that I
have been conducting over the past
several years which is actually a
vaginal microbiome study to look more
into the pathogenesis of incident BV
because we had been on the gardnerella
vaginalis hypothesis however there are
some issues with that hypothesis as I
have been discussing during this
presentation so this current study that
I wanted to talk to you about today use
molecular methods to determine the
sequence of microbiological events
leading up to a new case of BV among
sexually active african-american women
who have sex with women and you may ask
why did I pick this particular
population of women to do the study in
and it's mainly because african-american
women have a high prevalence of BV as do
women who have sex with women and so I
thought they would be a more high-risk
population to study these
microbiological events leading up to
incident BV this was a prospective study
that we conducted here in Birmingham
Alabama at our local STD clinic at our
Health Department to enroll in the study
the women had to have normal vaginal
flora with no Amstel criteria and a
normal Nugent score and we follow them
daily with vaginal swabs for the
development of incident BV and we define
this as having a Nugent score of seven
to ten on at least two to three
consecutive days or for 90 days they
were followed in the study if they did
not develop incident BV we had
originally hypothesized that sexual
exposure to gardnerella was the inciting
event leading to the complex changes in
vaginal flora associate with BV we
thought that if gardnerella was the
initial insult then it's apparent and
establishment in the vaginal microbiome
would be seen in women who develop
incident BV prior to increases in some
of these other key B be associated
bacteria and we also thought of BV as an
STD its incubation period should be
similar to other bacterial STI such as
gonorrhea which is usually between two
to seven days
we had screening methods for this study
which I have listed on the slide women
had to be female ages 18 to 45 have a
history of sex with another female
during the past year and have a current
female sex partner they could not have
used anti microbials within the past 14
days or had known HIV they could not be
pregnant or currently on their menstrual
period they also performed a urine
pregnancy test just to rule out women
who were pregnant and then they did a
sexual history and self collected
vaginal swabs for am so criteria and
Nugent score enrollment criteria for
this study as I mentioned they had to
have no tanto criteria Indonesian score
of 0 to 3 they could not be pregnant
they could not have trichomonas on a wet
mount and they could not have a
symptomatic vaginal yeast infection as
we thought these other conditions would
confound the vaginal microbiome data
related to BV if they were enrolled they
completed an enrolment study
questionnaire they had a pelvic exam
with specimens collected for gonorrhea
chlamydia and trichomonas nucleic acid
amplification testing they then practice
completion of their daily Diaries they
had sexual practices record on these
Diaries which I have a picture coming up
the next slide and then they self
collected two vaginal swabs for Nugent
score and vaginal microbiome sequencing
until the development of incident BV or
for 90 days participants were excluded
after initial enrollment if they had a
duplicate baseline Nugent score greater
than 3 which was read by our research
lab or if one of their NAT tests came
back positive for an STD
here's a copy of our daily study diary
which was a one-piece page of paper that
were given to participants and it asks a
variety of questions about their whether
or not they had sex that day their
partner gender partner types and race of
their partners in addition to a large
number of daily sexual practices whether
or not they were having symptoms and if
they were taking any mate medications on
that particular day
primary endpoint in this study was the
development of incident BZ as I
mentioned the daily vaginal gram stain's
were read all by myself and a second
reader we had a third if myself in the
second reader did not agree on a read we
had a third reader to do the tiebreaker
and then for women who had incident BB
and controls matched by age race and
menstrual cycle day who did not develop
incident B BB in the study and
maintained a normal Nugent score we did
DNA extraction on their vaginal swab
specimens in the 21 days leading up to
incident BB and every other day for
several days thereafter and then we
performed 16s rRNA gene sequencing
targeting the v4 region of the 16s gene
at a my seek machine this was done at
the Louisiana State University Health
Science Center with my colleagues Chris
Taylor and David Martin
we had a large bioinformatics pipeline
that was used to bring us down to the
species level of the vaginal bacteria in
the specimens in the study which I have
listed the methodology on the slide I'm
not going to go through this into detail
statistical analyses were also done that
were performed using our by my
biostatistics basically the longitudinal
microbiome data for BB candidate
bacteria which I mentioned to you
earlier and several lactobacillus
interests were analyzing the Philo seek
library the relative abundance of each
vaginal species per sample was the
measure used for analysis in the study
and we looked at percentile based
bootstrap confidence intervals to
evaluate the variation in trends of
abundance of bacterial species of
interest over time the results of this
study we enrolled for about three and a
half years enrollment completed last
year we had 203 women present to the
clinic for study screening interestingly
about 13% were not considered or
screened for the study for various
reasons of the remaining 176 screened
24% met all enrollment criteria and
consented to the study you may say well
why is it so low the women that got
enrolled into the study and it's mainly
because a lot of the women that we
screened had a Nugent score greater than
3 so they had abnormal vaginal flora at
baseline and were not eligible for the
study of the forty two women that were
enrolled 15 developed incident BB and
one was dropped due to having a
chlamydia diagnosis at baseline and then
16s sequencing was done for 14 incident
BB cases and eight women maintaining
normal vaginal flora to comprise a total
of 448 vaginal specimens
this table shows the characteristics of
women in the incident BV group in this
study compared to the women in the
normal group there were no significant
differences with regards to age and
other baseline demographic
characteristics history of sti's or
contraception use among women in this
study the next slide goes into the
results for this study we had heat maps
that were made for each of the women in
this study and due to the sake of time
I'm not going to go into all the details
on these heat maps but you can see the
changes in the vaginal floor that occur
in the women with incident BV and the
changes in some of the bacteria that are
going up and going down on these heat
maps if you refer to the paper listed on
the bottom right hand corner of the
slide we actually have a heat map for
all 14 women in this study they got
incident BV and on the next slide we
also have heat maps for the women in the
study that maintained a normal vaginal
flora so you can look at their heat maps
in comparison and contrast the heat maps
of the women that got incident BV if you
look at all the heat maps together to
summarize them the majority of women
that maintain normal vaginal flora had a
lactobacillus potus dominant vaginal
microbiota starting in the study in
contrast the majority of the women who
developed incident BV guts were
dominated by other lactobacilli
including inners and Jin seniya or
gasser I prior to the onset of BV the
onset of menses destabilized the vaginal
microbiota and preceded the development
of incident b bv and 35% of cases and in
some cases B be resolved on its own
after men say ceased interestingly in
addition the majority of BV cases had
detectable gardnerella vaginalis and
other BB associate bacteria prior to the
development of incident BV and sex
immediately preceded development of
incident BB by one to two days and sick
- 4 % of cases in this study
the next two slides show a specific
statistical analysis for specific BB
Associated bacteria and so these figures
can be a little complicated I just want
to review them very quickly basically on
the x-axis on the bottom of the slide
you can see the day's day zero is the
first day of incident BV and so if there
are - days on the bottom those are days
preceding incident BV and then on the
y-axis is the difference in the mean
relative abundance between incident BV
cases and women maintaining normal
vaginal flora in the study so we
actually found that private Ella bibby
a' became significantly higher in women
with incident BV four days before the
onset of infinite BV gardnerella
vaginalis became significantly higher
three days prior to incident BV and then
add up OB imagine a and Meg espera type
1 became significantly higher on the day
of incident BV and in those women
compared to women maintaining normal
vaginal flora when we looked at other
organisms including cynthia mongolia
lactobacillus iners and BB a B 1 2 & 3
the mean relative abundance of these
organisms was not significantly
different between groups in this study
prior to incident BV and so we basically
concluded that private ellaby be a
gardnerella at a podium and perhaps
Megara type 1 were key players in the
pathogenesis of incident BV also
importantly to mention in this study
sexual activity occurred in 93 percent
of women at a median of 4 days prior to
the development of incident BB so
similar to what I had mentioned earlier
if BB is a bacterial STD we think it's
incubation period may be anywhere
between 2 and 4 days based on the
results of this study also when we
looked at the very specific sexual
practices that we
elected in the daily diary in this study
we found that any sexual activity was
significantly associated with incident
BB having sex with a woman female
partner was significantly associated
with BV participating in any digital
vaginal sex was associated with BB any
digital anal sex was associated with BV
and using fingers or hand from the
vagina was significantly associated with
BB so all of these are sexual risk
factors that were significantly
associated with BV in this study so we
basically concluded that the onset of
menses and sexual activity were
destabilizing forces in the vaginal
microbiota in this study the relative
abundance of private Ella Bibby and
gardnerella became significantly higher
in women with incident BV starting four
days before and three days before the
onset and you may wonder well which one
came first and it's really hard to say
because we only collected daily vaginal
swab specimens I think that to really
tease out this issue in future studies
we have to collect more than once daily
vaginal swab specimens perhaps twice a
day or even three times a day to see
which one actually comes in first and
women getting incident BV in contrast as
I mentioned the relative abundance of
out of poem and mega Sparrow type one
became significantly higher and women on
the day of incident BV so later on and
then the relative abundance of other BB
Associated bacteria was not to make only
higher during infinite BV in this study
are several limitations of the study we
had a salt small sample size the
sensitivity of our Nugent's core can be
as low as 65% in the best of hands
these worse actually experienced women
in the study these were not virgins who
became sexually active so they're
probably not the optimal population as
they have several of them have had BV
before the survey questionnaire and
their daily diary data were based on
self-report and subject to bias from
that and then the controls were
currently based on women who maintain
normal vaginal flora we did not include
as controls women who developed
intermediate vaginal flora in this study
which should be looked at in the future
so we have somewhat refined our current
hypothesis for the pathogenesis of bv
based on the results of these studies we
basically think now that gardnerella is
necessary but not sufficient to perhaps
cause BV it may be that synergy between
prevotella Divya and gardnerella
vaginalis may be a second important
event causing BV and I've actually
reviewed the literature on this topic
recently and there was a study published
now in 1997 for more than 20 years ago
that basically showed that gardnerella
vaginalis and Provo television in vitro
have a highly synergistic relationship
where gardnerella vaginalis produces
amino acids that prep atella bivy a
utilizes and Prevage alibi BIA produces
ammonia that gardnerella vaginalis
utilize so this synergistic relationship
may be a key event at the beginning of
incident BV in addition there is
evidence in the literature of synergy
between gardnerella vaginalis and at a
podium vagine' a which also may be an
important event prior to BV development
it's known that at a podium vagine' a
rarely occurs in the absence of
gardnerella vaginalis and women with
Gardner L and at a podium have higher
rates of recurrent BV than women with
gardnerella alone in addition at a
podium stimulates an innate immune
response from vaginal epithelial cells
in greater magnitude than gardnerella
vaginalis suggesting that it is a potent
component of the host immune response to
VV and it may help to contribute to the
adverse reproductive and gynecologic
outcomes associated with BV and so now
we have revised our hypothetical model
for the pathogenesis of incident BV
which I have listed on this slide we're
currently in the process of writing this
up and getting it published but we have
four steps in this current model the
first step is a normal situation with a
layer of lactobacilli on the epithelial
cells of the normal vaginal microbiota
with a
low pH less than 4.5 we then think that
a virulent strain of gardnerella
vaginalis from sexual exposure still
displaces the vaginal lactobacilli and
initiates bv biofilm formation we think
then that proteolysis by gardnerella
produces these amino acids that I
mentioned enhance the growth of probe
atella by BIA and probe a television
perhaps may join the garner l vaginalis
biofilm this definitely needs to be
looked at to see if private ella is part
of the biofilm because it have not been
published to date that I'm aware of
then as I previously mentioned ammonia
produced by proto tell Olivia may
enhance gardnerella vaginalis growth and
then sigh ala days produced by both
private television and garner l may
promote breakdown of the mucin layer of
the vaginal epithelium and increased
adherence of these other strict
anaerobes that may be there and very
small numbers acquired from the mother
at birth this could include at a podium
vaginal and these bacteria may join the
upper layers of the bv biofilms without
the presence of vaginal lactobacilli and
with the emergence of an anaerobic mixed
species BV biofilm other indigenous
anaerobes may then be able to join and
their role in BB development is still
unknown
so this leads me to the end of this
presentation I know I've presented a lot
of data to you today and a lot of it is
controversial and so I'm happy if you
have any comments about any of the data
or hypotheses that I have talked about
today or any questions that I will be
more than happy to try to answer but I
appreciate you taking the time to listen
to this presentation my email address is
listed on the slide or you can also
email me through the lab group system
thank you very much and have a nice day